welcome to the man of recaps this is the
flash season 8. this season begins with
the armageddon crossover event although
it's not much of a crossover because the
arrowverse is basically done the villain
is despero an english soccer hooligan
from the future whose real form is a
giant pink alien but he's not here to
cause armageddon he's here to stop it by
killing the flash because turns out it's
the flash who goes crazy and destroys
the world now the flash can't beat this
guy with speed alone so he has to use
his real superpower revealing his secret
identity and having a heart-to-heart
talk that convinces him not to fight oh
talk new jutsu my only weakness so to
stop armageddon all barry has to do is
not go crazy but he immediately starts
to when he forgets that papa joe west
died then the flash attacks the city and
barry has no memory of it so barry
travels to the future to see how
armageddon happens turns out this is all
the doing of barry's arch nemesis eobard
thawne the reverse flash with his
harrison wells face he's altered the
timeline to create his own perfect world
where he is the flash and barry allen is
his villain a reverse flash since
barry's a villain in this timeline he
gets help from a villain damien dark but
remember in the main timeline he had a
redemption arc when he sacrificed
himself to save his daughter nora on
legends of tomorrow and turns out the
secret to resetting the timeline is you
guessed it run really fast so fast in
fact it would destroy the world yeah
this is how barry causes armageddon but
with the power of iris's love he's able
to run fast enough to outrun armageddon
and the day is saved despero still
decides to be a bad guy for some reason
so barry runs real fast and kicks him in
the face but now the reverse flash has
followed him here and we finally get the
answer to why he hates the flash so much
he wanted to be a hero but the flash was
faster than him so instead he decided to
be a villain and kill the flash but now
he's being erased from the timeline and
instead of letting that happen barry
decides to save him by taking away his
speed which he is none too pleased about
and swears his vengeance so with
armageddon over the flash gets back to
his usual antics he faces the royal
flush gang whose superpowers seem to be
making really lame card puns the theme
of this season is that team flash is all
leveled up like barry so fast now
one-off villains of the week like this
are not even a threat anymore his wife
iris has leveled up too the central city
citizen is super successful and now it's
time for allegra to level up as she's
promoted to supervising editor a boring
subplot which gets a ton of screen time
in her second job at star labs there's
an office romance blooming between
allegra and team flash's new science guy
chester p runk he gets an unresolved
mini subplot where he's a science
streamer but one day one of his viewers
uses science for evil but he sorts it
out it was just an accident but turns
out it wasn't now this guy's hacked his
computer so watch out for that dr
caitlin snow remember now has a separate
body from her alter ego frost and things
are heating up between frost and chill
blaine which caitlyn does not approve of
in the future barry and iris's grown-up
kids nora and bart get up to shenanigans
they travel to our time for a minor
timeline fix but instead bart meets a
hot scientist and they start dating papa
joe west is happily retired from ccpd
the new police chief is kristin kramer
who found out last season she's a meta
two who can temporarily borrow the
powers from nearby metas barry finally
trusts her enough to reveal he's the
flash but she's like yeah man i mean
it's super obvious if you're curious
about leftover cliffhangers from arrow
one day mia queen oliver's daughter
shows up to explain why she's not
getting her own series and remember john
diggle found the green lantern ring but
he rejects it cause that series ain't
happening either now there's a new
villain in town it's some super scary
smoke it does kill people though but not
with hot fire with cold fusion it feeds
on people's grief like chester p ranks
sees his dead dad but it's obviously not
him to caitlyn's note appears as her
dead fiance ronnie but it's obviously
not him but turns out it actually is him
but turns out it's actually not him it
was just using his body for science
reasons his real identity is just a
sentient cold fusion monster called
death storm the secret to defeating him
is for frost to level up and get her own
cold fusion powers now she's hell frost
and she's able to eat this guy but
what's this i don't feel so good mr
stark the power overloads her and frost
dies team flash is devastated as if
they've forgotten people die all the
time and they always come back through
science or time travel but caitlyn's
resolved to save her sister she turns
her apartment into a secret science lab
and recruits chillblane to bring frost
back barry doesn't approve though and
pulls a hugely dick move and wrecks her
apartment which is a good way to push
your friend away and turn them into a
villain meanwhile there's a new
speedster in central city but it's a
good guy it's dr mina dawon she's built
a super advanced artificial speed giver
but turns out her partner is the ia bard
thon finally wearing his own face but
this version of him really is a good guy
the evil harrison wellstone is still
locked up with no speed but good thon
didn't know his machine accidentally
taps into the negative speed force which
turns mina into a villain luckily he and
mina have a romance going so with the
power of love she's not evil and she
gets to be a good guy speedster named
fast track meanwhile iris has caught a
time sickness which starts erasing
things from the timeline luckily she's
friends with the time force dion who's
actually called the still force and he
tries to help but he gets infected too
and now that's freed the evil negative
forces with the power of love and or
science mina's able to share her speed
with good thon so barry's got some
speedster backup for this final fight
these two do the standard move of
running around uselessly while barry
does a standard move of running real
fast and throwing a lightning bolt but
this was the negative forces planned all
along as they teleport tire is here and
oh it's too late to stop it barry kills
iris but she doesn't die she turns into
green dust and goes into good thon and
for reasons i can't even begin to
explain he's transformed into evil
harrison wellstone the negative forces
make him their avatar and he gets a huge
power boost and a super cool new suit
iris meanwhile doesn't die she's hanging
out with damien dark inside his time
stone and he tells her the secret of how
to just decide not to be dead anymore
cecile by the way has leveled up her own
powers this season in fact she's able to
talk with the good forces and put on the
mask which somehow brings them back the
positive forces make barry their avatar
and now barry's got a superpower up into
rainbow flash so barry and thon have
their final classic speedster battle in
the end though barry realizes the only
way to win is not to fight thon goes the
other way with it tries to destroy the
whole universe but it's too much power
and now he's exploded erased from the
timeline again for good this time so the
day is saved as we wrap things up cecile
now gets telekinetic power for some
reason and caitlyn snow is going ahead
with her dangerous plan to revive her
sister frost does it work we'll find out
and the negative forces were beaten but
not defeated in the future they're
choosing a new avatar but no matter how
many times they come back team flash
will be ready to stop him well at least
one more time because season 9 is
finally the final season and that's
where the flash season 8 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]